this video was sponsored by blinkist so
let's say you're an idealist i was
recently inspired by the ideas of
universal basic income free healthcare
or completely opposite ideas like
smaller limited government to let the
free market do its thing
whatever it is you believe that if we
just tried this out just for a little
bit it would work and lift
tons of people out of poverty stop crime
and bring prosperity to all
and for good reason experimenting with
new ideas is what has led to every
single new invention
innovation and change that we take for
granted today so it only makes sense
that we should
experiment with how we govern over
people to experiment with the rules that
we set for society
so you set out to put your plan into
action to change the rules of the game
you quickly run into the wall of slow
inefficient politicians and bureaucrats
or in other words you've run into the
classic problem of monopolies
except in this case it's not a monopoly
on oil railroad social media platforms
but a monopoly on the most
important business the business of
governance there aren't two
u.s federal governments competing for
your tax dollars but only one that
you're forced to pay or get thrown into
prison
in fact if we treat a government as an
industry it's by far the largest in the
world accounting for 30
of global gdp and it's the industry that
affects every single aspect of your life
yes to you watching this video
your life down to the thoughts you're
allowed to think and yet it's the
slowest industry in the world that's the
most difficult to innovate in
where the poorest performers kill their
own customers we've had the agricultural
revolution the commercial and industrial
revolution and we're in the age of
information right now
but why not a revolution in the most
important arena
a governance revolution
the unlikely answer to sparking this new
revolution
the sea enter seasteading or floating
cities on the sea where aquatic citizens
live in modular pods that can detach and
join other cities at any time
and since they would be in international
water cities would be able to govern
themselves where instead of you being
forced to put up with your government
governments are forced to compete for
citizens like companies can be for
customers
where instead of you trying to change
the rules of a monopoly if you like the
laws of another floating city you can
easily leave and join that one
where instead of debating and screaming
at each other about political ideas like
universal basic
income or whatever you can test them in
real life against reality and let the
better idea win
a silicon valley of governance if you
will arguments don't change the world
startups change the world where instead
of just leaving your livelihood behind
when a storm hits the coastal city that
you live in
we can take your city and
that idea may just be crazy enough
to work maybe patrick was right or c
says as we're calling it on the hardware
of society and the rules or laws we
choose or the software to create new
societies
but wait before you think this is some
science fiction pipe dream before you
call this impossible
we already have cities and other giant
structures on the sea
they're called cruise ships japan's many
giant airport islands
container ships shells floating natural
gas facility that's longer than the
empire state building
nuclear submarines nuclear aircraft
carriers that can stay at sea for 15 to
20 years before refueling and many more
examples
everything about sea setting is
counterintuitive but solutions to the
most difficult problems are always
counter-intuitive otherwise we would
have already thought of them by now
this is the race for the aquatic age
[Music]
the basic idea around c-sets are rather
simple and as we mentioned before
almost all the technology needed to make
this work already exist
it's just a matter of taking those
technologies and putting them together
and at the end of the day it's just a
bunch of interchangeable floating
modules that can connect together to
allow humans to eat
sleep work and play on the ocean instead
of roads you maybe have little rivers to
travel around in boats like in miami or
venice the floating platform can be
built out of steel
concrete or fiber composites like carbon
fiber all of which are already used in
water related projects
but each having their own pros and cons
like how long they'll last price
weight etc the bigger you build the
platform the more stable it is against
waves
which provides the incentive to make
ocean cities big once you have the
platforms you can build anything on top
of it
housing offices hotels walkable green
space
ports power generators like how we
already have floating solar fields and
shell's natural gas
facility and cruise ships are the
perfect example of ocean cities
they have more amenities than the
average town you sign a contract before
you board for their own medical and
security staff and since the business
model and the man is there it's not that
expensive
take this 18 night cruise that travels
all over europe for example
an inside cabin will cost you 66 dollars
per day or around 2
000 per month not including other
expenses and that's still two times
cheaper than the average apartment in
manhattan while traveling all over
europe
if you want a cabin with a view that
would cost you around a hundred dollars
a night or three thousand dollars per
month
still cheaper than manhattan but jake
that doesn't count you can't live on a
cruise ship forever
or can you meet mama lee her and her
husband fell in love with cruising so
when he passed away
his last words to mama lee were to never
stop cruising
and that's what she's been doing for
over a decade now with the break during
quarantine and has been loving
every single part of it or take mario
saucedo for example
another full-time cruiser who's taken
over 2 000 cruises in the last 20 years
cruise ships are also already taking
advantage of the fact that they operate
in international waters like our ocean
cities would
they register their ships in countries
like panama liberia or the marshall
islands where there are less regulations
lower taxes or the country doesn't have
enough resources to enforce their
regulations on these ships or in other
words cruise ships are already ahead of
the game
since they're seabourn they already get
to choose what governments they want to
work with
and guess what at one point people
probably thought cruise ships were
impossible as well
as we mentioned before there are many
other examples of the coming aquatic age
that we don't have time to go into
detail with
japan with their rugged terrain high
population density and zoning issues
forced them to expand their airports
onto the ocean
the dutch are conveniently nested
between the world's largest sea gay
holding back the north sea
and the snow melt from the alps that's
why they already have amphibious houses
[Music]
what's the difference between north
korea and south korea they're on the
same peninsula they have access to the
same resources and when the north and
south split back in 1948
most of the people from both nations
came from the same families with only an
imaginary line separating the two or a
very real line in the case of the dmz
and yet today almost a century later
when you look at the area from above at
night you see south korea japan china
gleaming with prosperity
and then there's the black hole of north
korea where the rural areas are darker
than some parts of the oceans
25 million people living in complete
darkness with food shortages suffering
the whole nine yards
yet travel just a few miles south of
that border and you see the happy
citizens of south korea enjoying all the
fruits of a modern society
what is the difference between the two
simple the rules the laws how they
govern over their subjects
what are the rules now you may be saying
to yourself but jake north korea is a
very special case you can't come to this
conclusion from just this one
outlier but what about the dominican
republic versus haiti
similar situation they share the same
island and resources yet the border
between them can be clearly seen from
space
not because of a border wall or river
separating the two but because the
dominican side is filled with forestry
while the other side looks pretty much
dead
just like the koreans the only thing
separating the two is the artificial
lines humans made up and the rules that
govern each side
now maybe that example is a special case
too but when you consider all the other
examples like east versus west germany
hong kong the land of billionaires
versus mainland china
singapore versus malaysia greece versus
albania and you will see that the only
distinction
comes down to the rules what are the
rules
[Music]
that is how powerful rules the laws of a
society are they determine how high you
can climb how prosperous you can be how
long you live on average how happy
you'll be on average
and the list goes on and on the world
bank figured this out ten years ago
exhaustive study determining what makes
countries rich
the most valuable thing in the world
is the rule of law you plant from which
everything else sprouts
so if worlds are so important how do we
change them and how might cease that
help
well since the agricultural revolution
all wealth and power came from those
that were able to control
land rulers dictators military leaders
often involving bloodshed
power and wealth also came to those who
were able to innovate on top of that
land
building farms businesses etc and in the
early days it used to be that once you
discovered new land you could set up a
colony try out your own set of rules and
see how it fares
that's the exact story of america they
discovered the new world set up shop and
experimented with the crazy idea that
power rested in the people
not the government an idea that was so
out of the realm of understanding at the
time that everyone thought would fail
that people in europe refer to it as the
american experiment
this experiment worked out so well that
the radical idea of limited
representative democracy is now the
industry standard around the world
today there might well be the next
american experiment waiting to be
discovered the problem is
there are no more new worlds to be
discovered on this planet one way we've
gotten around this is with special
economic zones
and it all started with hong kong
[Music]
in short hong kong was ruled by the
british after world war ii until they
eventually gave it back to china in
1997.
because of the different rules the
british had in hong kong compared to the
planning economy in mainland china
hong kong's wealth skyrocketed during
the second half of the 1900s
and over the next 36 years the wealth of
the average person
in hong kong watched this slide grew
87 times china was so impressed by hong
kong that it created a bunch of other
special economic zones all over the
country
and the same things happened today hong
kong has the most expensive real estate
in the world and has the second most
billionaires in the world behind
new york shenzhen another special
economic zone in china has risen to the
hardware capital of the world
and is known as the most futuristic city
as well all because of what do you know
a different set of rules so in 1979
when it was designated a special
economic zone
shenzhen didn't even have a traffic
light and this is what happened in 25
years
so today shenzhen manufactures 90
percent of computer keyboards
ninety percent of computer mice and
ninety percent
of shenzhen's population are migrant
workers
at least a half billion people
escaped extreme poverty as they migrated
to these special economic zones
but china isn't alone other countries
have acted as special economic zones as
well
take singapore for example singapore
also doesn't have many natural resources
like hong kong besides their harbor they
have universal health care yet the
government makes more money than it
spends
they follow typical english laws yet
they dish out death sentences over zoom
if you're caught with over 15 grams of
heroin
and like china's special economic zones
singapore went from half of the
population being illiterate to one of
the richest countries in asia
nordic countries like sweden denmark and
norway are also kind of like special
economic zones
except they take a very different
approach instead of low taxes low
regulations they have high personal
taxes very generous welfare services
their people works on the lowest amount
of hours on the planet
and yet they're overall some of the most
happiest people on the planet too
[Music]
so what's the answer more welfare or
less government taxes and spending
the answer is we haven't had enough
experiments to find out you probably
heard of thomas edison's quote about how
it took him 10 000 tries to invent the
light bulb
he was probably exaggerating but the
point remains if it takes that many
tries to invent a simple
invention in retrospect how can we ever
hope to find the answer to the extremely
complex question of how to organize
millions of people
all with their own self-interests
problems desires when we only have 195
countries and a little over 500 special
economic zones in the world
a little over 700 experiments running in
the world
plus the fallen civilizations of the
past now that may sound like a lot but
at this rate we will never get to the
answer to the most impactful business to
mankind
you don't discover the most miraculous
societies
by trying one hong kong here one
singapore over there
or even 30 free zones in dubai
you need thousands of startup societies
exploring the future discovering the
best ways of governing ourselves
as long as people can join them
voluntarily
and leave them voluntarily we will
engage
a evolutionary market process
and solutions will emerge that we can't
imagine now
we need more special economic zones the
problem with special economic zones is
that they're too
far and few between number one there's
no new land to colonize you could take
away more land from local populations by
force but that's probably not a good
idea
number two it requires global
superpowers like the us and china to
relinquish more of their power to turn
their existing land into special
economic zones
and as we all know once you get power
it's very hard to let go of it
and number three special economic zones
benefit from being in prime locations
where a lot of trade can happen
all the special economic zones we talked
about happen to all be touching the
ocean as it turns out so maybe there is
something to the ocean
singapore and hong kong won the real
estate lottery and if real estate is
location location location
what if you could choose your location
instead of being content with the hand
you were dealt
that is why we need sea stats or special
economic zones sees this to be exact
because floating cities are mobile they
can position themselves in the most
profitable areas around
the world they would allow more of these
experiments and governance to happen
that skyrocketed places like hong kong
to the stratosphere without trying to
overhaul existing governments
and since people can choose which cities
they join at any time a government
dissolving or not being effective
wouldn't lead to war or people starving
to death either
sea setting isn't necessarily the answer
to our most complex problems
the answer is more experiments in
government and until superpowers are
willing to give up some of their power
in a timely manner until humans are able
to move their homes and leave and join
governments easier
or until the cost of creating space
colonies goes way down sea setting in
international water seems to be the path
of least resistance
if you're gonna start your own floating
city you're gonna need a ton of
knowledge
everything from science business
economics politics and everything in
between
and it's so easy to make the excuse that
you don't have time to read all these
books
in fact that's personally my main
bottleneck right now trying to make more
time for reading
this is where blinkist comes in blinkist
takes the best most popular nonfiction
books and turns them into 15 minute
discoveries that you can listen to
during your commute
while you clean etc that way you can
take back some of your wasted time and
turn them into productive
easy moments for learning they have a
lot of my favorite books on there like
the lean startup
deep work and a lot of books that i've
always wanted to read but they just
never became the number one thing that i
need to learn at the time so i never got
to them
but now i can go ham on all these books
and read the full versions afterwards if
i really like them we live in the golden
age of information people in
absolute poverty around the world would
kill to know english to be able to take
advantage of all this knowledge
and yet if you ask yourself are you
really making the most of all this
knowledge
like myself the answer is probably a
hard no that's why blinkist is offering
the first 100 people who sign up with
the link below
unlimited free access for a week to try
it out and 25
off if you want the full membership
afterwards so you and i
we're gonna stop making excuses we're
gonna join the other 14 million people
using blankets to make the most
out of this beautiful time that we're
living in while supporting the brands
that help make this channel possible too
again the first 100 people who click the
link below will get free access for a
week and 25
off if you want to join afterwards
[Music]
would you guys want to live on the sea
people already do it in like shipping
containers and cruise ships and oil rigs
and i'm not sure my opinion on it maybe
but let me know what you guys think in
the comments below i am definitely
considering being a full-time cruiser
though that sounds pretty fun
huge shout out to the c-setting
institute and their president joe quirk
they're the ones really spearheading
this movement and that's who you saw in
all those clips
highly recommend joe's book on c-setting
because i only got to cover like a small
slither of all the
information and benefits that are in
that book so yeah that will be linked
below and i highly recommend if you want
more videos on this subject like maybe
like some updates or whatever if they
come
up just let me know in the comments
below if you're still watching this
right now and you're new to this channel
you might as well subscribe because we
make videos like this
every single week for free that you can
dislike and unsubscribe from whenever
you want so you might as well click that
subscribe button because it really helps
out a ton
if you want to support this channel
financially check out today's sponsor if
you want memes behind the scenes stuff
day in the life kind of stuff
like sneak peeks on new videos and stuff
you can follow me on instagram
jaketrend.io that is gonna wrap it up
for this video thank you so much for
watching i really do mean that by the
way
you've been awesome i've been jake i'll
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you